cyberpunk 2077 finally has flying cars
blizzard details junker queen and more
when you think about a futuristic world
what do you think of for me i think
about neon lights and flying cars cd
projekt red cyberpunk 2077 launched with
lots of neon but unfortunately no
airborne traffic luckily jack humbert
has fulfilled my dreams and created a
mod called let there be flight that lets
players fly cars and bikes around night
city and these aren't your standard gta
cheat code looking flying cars either
this mod has an animation for the wheels
that turns them into thrusters i'll
leave the link to humber's creation in
the description as well as a link to
last known meals full videos showcasing
the mod and explaining installation in
other fps related news blizzard has
finally given fans a more detailed look
at the abilities of junker queen over
watch 2's newest hero a front-line tank
junker queen is all about getting up
close and personal and dealing damage
with her battle axe and scattergun's
shotgun you'll be able to inflict wounds
on enemies using melee attacks from her
axe as well as hits from her carnage
ability or ultimate ability rampage
wounds not only deal damage over time to
enemies but heal junker queen thanks to
her adrenaline rush passive ability her
axe can be thrown to deal damage from
range and in true god of war fashion can
be recalled with the press of a button
junker queen's commanding shout ability
will increase both her health and the
health of nearby allies while also
granting her a 30
movement speed boost junker queen will
be playable in the second round of the
overwatch 2 beta which starts on june
28th but if you and your squad need
something to play even sooner then call
of duty season 4 might be for you the
season is being dubbed the mercenaries
of fortune and sea's now feuding
operators from vanguard battling over
gold for warzone there will be a brand
new fortunes keep resurgence map which
will be much like rebirth island's close
quarters and respawning action but now
with the new castle island setting this
new map will also add new contracts like
the black market run and cash extraction
for vanguards multiplayer season 4 is
adding two new maps one is a reimagining
of the uss texas map from call of duty
world war ii and the second will arrive
later in the season and is called
desolation on june 21st for vanguard and
on june 22nd for warzone at the same
time the updates will be available to
download at 9am pacific 12pm eastern on
june 21st for vanguard and at those same
times on june 22nd for warzone something
else that's happening on june 22nd is a
nintendo direct for xenoblade chronicles
3. the presentation will start at 7 a.m
pacific 10 a.m eastern and will feature
around 20 minutes of information about
the game let me know in the comments if
you want flying cars to be a regular
thing in real life and i'll see you in
the next one
you